[Music]
war in Yemen war in Syria confrontation
with Iran a diplomatic crisis with Qatar
and now to top it all off the
coronavirus crisis and the devastating
collapse in oil prices the Persian Gulf
countries have been living on the brink
of a nervous breakdown for a few years
now and we're talking about some of the
richest countries in the world at least
given the immense fortunes that the
royal families that govern these
countries control look for example at
this chart from the consulting firm
Oliver Wyman in early 2020 the
consulting firm estimated that the six
countries that make up the Persian Gulf
Cooperation Council namely Saudi Arabia
the United Arab Emirates Kuwait Oman
Bahrain and Qatar controlled assets
worth almost a staggering 44 trillion
dollars yes trillions three point three
trillion dollars invested through its
sovereign wealth funds and just over 40
trillion in oil and natural gas reserves
to give you an idea that works out to
more than 1.3 million per inhabitant
this is a huge source of wealth that
these countries could use to maintain
very high living standards modernized
their economies and maintain significant
global influence however the coronavirus
crisis has turned all these forecasts
upside down and left us with news like
this jobless migrants fleeing reach
countries to the chagrin of their home
countries lesions of foreign workers are
leaving Gulf nations wall street
journal'
so what is going on in the Petro
monarchies and in the Persian Gulf what
sort of future do they face is their
story of money riches and power come in
to an end which countries will be most
affected in this video we will answer
all these questions but first we will
answer a question that many of you must
have asked yourself more than once why
on earth should I care what happens in a
part of the world where there is little
more than deserts and camels why should
we care what happens in the Persian Gulf
well let's find out
[Applause]
[Music]
virtually every economy in the world is
suffering from the effects of SARS co2
and certainly the countries in the
Persian Gulf are no exception of course
they are facing a double crisis a one
hand like most countries they have to
put in place social distancing and
confinement measures and to close public
spaces and businesses on the other hand
they're dealing with a huge fall in oil
prices there has been a direct result of
the sudden and unprecedented collapse in
demand to give you an idea during the
first five months of 2020 the price of
oil fell by almost 50 percent and that's
despite these countries cutting
production and of course rock-bottom
prices and lower production means far
far less revenue for Gulf petro
monarchies the amounts involved is so
large that more than a couple of you
would be left speechless but why should
we care about all this
well let's say that from a geostrategic
point of view the Persian Gulf countries
are much more important than we might
think at first glance and their
importance is based on these three
factors okay so the first one I'm sure
I'm sure you are very clear about this
region is home to the largest oil and
natural gas deposits on the planet
approximately 35 percent of all oil
produced in the world comes from the
Persian Gulf but that's not all
the second reason this part of the world
is so important is because of its key in
world trade it's usually something that
goes unnoticed but this area of the
world is a key hub for the world's
busiest sea and air routes most routes
connecting Asia Africa and Europe pass
through here that explains why some of
the largest ports and airports on the
planets are located in this region but
if you want a more concrete example
check this out 18 percent of all global
rice production 16% of all wheat
production and 30% of the fertilizer
trade passes through this region and of
course if instead of rice or wheat we
talk about Chinese manufacturing the
situation is not dissimilar we need the
Middle East not for its oil but
precisely because it sits in the middle
of a global market that secures our
global energy supply and even more
important because the Middle East
facilitates the transit of the goods
that we and other countries use to grow
carrying a young a resident scholar at
the American Enterprise Institute and
then finally we cannot forget the
enormous religious and social weight
these countries have in the Muslim
community around the world in a nutshell
those are the three reasons why the
Persian Gulf is so important
[Music]
and let's not forget that these
countries have some of the largest
reserves of money in the world we're
talking about almost three and a half
trillion Petrov dollars that is these
countries alone could put the entire
world's financial books in order now
that's really saying something however
in spite of everything the last few
years have not exactly been good for any
of these countries and now the
coronavirus threatens to be the last
straw in this video we're going to focus
on the six countries that make up the
Persian Gulf Cooperation Council but if
we also take Iraq and Iran into account
then the result could be even worse but
how are things really in this part of
the world when we say that the last few
years have been bad what exactly do we
mean what is the real scale of the
problem let's take a look a waning
fortune
okay it's not the same to face a problem
with almost three and a half trillion
dollars in your pocket then it is
without them the golf shakes wallet is
still full however this huge stash of
cash might be hiding a new reality we
could be looking at one of those
situations where you can't see the
forest for the trees now let me explain
according to data from the International
Monetary Fund in the last four years
alone the net financial assets held by
the six Persian Gulf monarchies have
been reduced to 500 billion dollars and
that's not all
this year all these countries are
expected to close with double-digit
deficits in 2020 alone the shakes are
going to lose more than 220 yes two
hundred and twenty billion dollars over
the course of a year
[Music]
and I know what some of you were
thinking come on Josh 220 billion
dollars that's rough but they will still
have more than three trillion bucks in
their pocket what's the problem well if
you think like this you're not taking
into account some of the finer details
for example the IMF has estimated that
if things don't change dramatically the
Gulf Petro monarchies will see their
enormous financial wealth just disappear
in just over a decade and take note
because we are talking about money that
is supposedly meant to ensure the
economic viability of countries that
have a very young population a lack of
jobs and which today remain completely
dependent on the price of oil this
dependence is the reason why these
countries have launched all kinds of
multi-million dollar projects to try and
diversify their economies and generate
new sources of wealth over the past two
decades in the early 2020s alone real
estate mega projects in the Gulf
accumulated committed investments worth
almost one trillion dollars now we are
talking about mega ports new cities
built from scratch stadiums resorts etc
etcetera however such initiatives have
generally had disappointing outcomes a
lot of money have been spent to get
rather poor results and to top it all
off now because of the coronavirus
projects built over the last few years
promised to reap huge losses you see the
mighty petro monarchies in the Gulf now
face an uncertain future they have to
maintain a high standard of living with
dwindling fortunes very young cities
with high rates of population growth and
ever-increasing levels of unemployment
if the crisis and oil prices do not
recover soon these countries could have
a very hard time of course not all
countries are the same Saudi Arabia for
example is one of the countries that
could suffer the worst over the next few
years let's take a look
a great power with leaden feets
according to news headlines during the
coronavirus crisis we might think that
sound Arabia is calmly taking advantage
of the chaos to build its strength
Sardi's sovereign wealth fund by Styx
and Facebook Boeing Cisco Systems Wall
Street Journal a bargain hunter who has
even just bought a football team
Saudi wealth fun agrees to 300 million
pound deal to buy Newcastle United
Financial Times
however hold on a moment because the
reality is very very different
[Music]
in the last decade Saudi Arabia has
tried to become a superpower over the
past 10 years this country has had the
third largest military budget in the
world behind only the United States and
China three billion dollars five hundred
and thirty three million dollars five
hundred and twenty five million dollars
that's peanuts for you
who's triggered its own war in Yemen and
has had a very heavy-handed foreign
policy the blockade of Qatar and the
conflict with Iran have been good
evidence of this
[Music]
and as you can imagine these whims have
not been cheat since 2015 Saudi Arabia's
public deficit has averaged nearly 11
percent each year this has caused the
government reserves the Saudi Treasury
to have shrunk by more than 200 billion
dollars while its public debt has
increased fivefold from 5 to 25 percent
of GDP and now coronavirus and the
collapse in the oil price are going to
cause the 2020 deficit to far exceed a
hundred billion dollars
that is at this rate in just over three
years all accumulated oil wealth could
disappear be gone completely and that
would create a very difficult halter
plug because the Saudi economy basically
depends on public spending you will
reduce expenditure if God wills even if
some of the steps taken will be painful
but they are for the benefit of everyone
for the benefit of the country and for
the benefit of the citizens welcome at
algid on finance minister of Saudi
Arabia and that's precisely what they've
done
[Music]
so far the Saudi government has already
announced that it will triple the tax on
purchases v80 from 5% to 15% it will
also cut employee pay by 270 dollars a
month and put on hold many of the
investment projects the country had
launched to try and diversify its
economy however none of this may be
enough in Saudi Arabia the vast majority
of society lives directly or indirectly
from public spending and that way of
life is what maintains stability and
loyalty to the Saudi royal family
the ruling royal family the government
understands that in this case the carts
have a limit but what does this
situation mean for the future well I
think we can say that the long term
scenario could be very good or very bad
for the rest of the world let me explain
with a very young population and an
unemployment rate that will soon exceed
15% the crisis may force the Saudis to
reform the country from top to bottom
which would be reasonably good or in
contrast it may fuel the discourse of
the most radical religious leaders as
was the case in the 1990s and that would
be bad something really bad for everyone
but Saudi Arabia is not the only country
with problems even places as rich as
Kuwait or Dubai now face severe
turbulence take a look
the pearls of the Gulf
until it was invaded by Saddam Hussein's
troops in 1990 Kuwait was considered the
Pearl of the Persian Gulf
a stable tremendously rich country with
some of the most advanced institutions
in the region indeed curates political
system is considered akin to a
parliamentary monarchy all adult men and
since 2006
also women with Kuwaiti nationality have
the right to vote every four years a
unicameral parliament is elected that
appoints the Prime Minister passes laws
oversees the government and approves
budgets
and it's also a tremendously rich
country it's basically a small state
that sits on gigantic oil fields to give
you an idea while the population with
creating nationality amounts to just
over 1 million inhabitants proven crude
oil reserves exceed a hundred billion
barrels the sixth largest reserves on
the planet a situation in which this
small country has managed to create a
huge sovereign wealth fund the Kuwait
Investment Authority which has invested
more than 500 billion dollars worldwide
stocks real estate debt gold and perhaps
that's also why it's the Gulf country
that has made the least effort over the
past few decades to diversify its
economy to such an extent that today
more than 90% of the government's total
revenue depends directly on black gold
and therefore it follows that if the
price of oil sinks you can already
imagine what happens to the accounts of
this small country
between failing oil prices and the
government plans to deal with the
coronavirus crisis the National Bank of
Kuwait one of the largest local banks
has predicted that the public deficit
will be 40 percent of GDP in 2020 yes
yes that's right 40 percent of GDP
clearly his situation is very different
from that of Saudi Arabia their reserves
of money and oil per capita are much
larger
but even this country has problems with
a rapidly growing population
Kuwait increasingly knees higher oil
prices to balance its budgets meanwhile
the other great pearl of the Gulf Dubai
also faces serious problems
[Music]
although Debye is not so dependent on
oil the problem has been the collapse of
tourism and commercial activities the
two great areas in which this city
specializes a city that counts among its
assets the largest International Airport
in the world one of the largest airlines
the largest shopping center the most
luxurious hotel and one of the 10
largest ports on the planet joint
projects that have essentially been
financed with debt to give you an idea
according to the consulting firm Capital
Economics devised sovereign debt amounts
to 110 percent of GDP while the debt of
public companies is another 80 percent
in total almost 200 percent debt over
GDP and now the coronavirus is making
news like this seventy percent of dubai
companies expect to go out of business
within six months due to coronavirus
pandemic
survey says CNBC and this is something
that adds to the situation that was
already fragile as we mentioned earlier
Dubai's economy has been pretty bad for
a few years for example since 2014
property prices have fallen by 30
percent and that's not all now the city
faces a whole exodus of expats that will
reduce is population which creates
another problem a lower population means
less occupied housing less consumption
etc we are facing a minimum population
contraction of 10% during 2020 nasser
al-sheikh former head of Dubai's finance
department of course dubai keeps an ace
up its sleeve they can always phone a
friend like back in 2009 when their
comrade and neighbour abu dhabi richest
emirate in the world came to their aid
and leds dubai all the money that they
needed of course the question that many
may ask is what will abu dhabi ask in
return what trade-offs will it demand
can do by reinvent itself again anyway
this is the situation that the petra
monarchies of the persian gulf are going
through today as you could see
coronavirus has wreaked havoc even in
some of the richest places on earth and
the question is all these countries
managed to reinvent themselves can they
escape their oil addiction leave your
answer in the comments so I really hope
you enjoyed this video please hit like
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
media pod
they provided the vocals at this episode
that weren't mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always I'll see you in
the next video if you want to learn more
about politics and world affairs and
here's some more of my lovely voice come
check out the reconsidered podcast where
we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider at WWE consider mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcast
[Music]
[Applause]